[Musique]
ce serait génial
moi je suis fan de toi en tout cas je
trouve que tu es un amant câble de la
sueur de l'émission mais comment
parce que je trouve qu il se sort de
tout situation est très calme fait
beaucoup rire de réussir à bien parler
pendant l'émission a expliqué un petit
peu en quoi consiste le cabaret voilà de
le voir une guerre nucléaire
[Musique]
je suis le mois de janvier et c'est un
mois qui débute c'est la roma dit
aujourd'hui je suis une grande fan de
lady gaga serait instagram
je me réveille je mange je dors à g
non je trouve que c'est un endroit
particulièrement créatif où on peut
s'exprimer christine sur l'univers
j'adore j'ai dit que je l'aimais bien
j'aime pas non plus jusqu'à danser la
valse tu sais ce qui dans ce nom ou
pérou au brésil très envie de m
je l'avais déclara drôle sexy incroyable
avec des chanteurs et danseurs des
musiciens des acrobates des magiciens
bref venez
[Musique]